Selam
gençler Merhaba
Abi ben Mustafa Can namıdiğer Kaptan
Mustafa Can
1964 Ankara doğumluyum size ya
o özellikle ailemin işte şimdi kaybettin
dediğinde
kazançlarını anlatacağım bu
m57 yaşıma kadar yani 20 20 yaşından
37 yılda yaşadıklarımın kısa bir özeti
olacak
o zaman dar anlatacağım şeyler
Bu parça parça olacak ama umarım size
bir damla
anlatacaklarım dan cesaret bir damla
ne verebilirsen benim ülkeme ülkemin
gençleri ne güvendiğim sizlere göre
evlerinden birini daha yapmış olacağım
arkadaşlar
Ben 18 yaşında bu Orta Doğu Teknik
Üniversitesini kazandım peşine
aynı anda karar okulunu kazandım o
zamanlar benim zamanlarımda Ankara'nın
içinde üniformalarıyla gezerdi karar
Okulu mevcut talebeleri ve çok da sikse
yaparlardı gençlerin rüyasıydı Oraya
girmek burayı 3. olarak kazandım tabi
ailem Çok sevindi ve aynı anda Orta Doğu
Teknik Üniversitesini kazandım
Bu askerlik Aslında hayallerimde
gördüklerinde vardı fakat bir gün içinde
o asker harp okulunun içine girdiğimde
asker olamayacağımı bu Emir altında
Emirler altında yaşayacağım
yaşayamayacağını ne yazık ki oraya adım
attığımda fark ettim geri dönmek o kadar
zordu ki Arkadaşlar yani ben vazgeçtim
demek herkes için zordu benim için ailem
için ailemin komşularına karşı durumu
için Düşünsenize o oğlum benim subay
olacak gene Paşa olacak General olacak
Genelkurmay olacak ve hatta Eskiden
öyleydi O cumhurbaşkanı olacak
genelkurmay başkanları Cumhurbaşkanı
oluyordu biliyorsunuz bir zamanda
ve ben vazgeçtim bir gün ertesi gün ben
asker olamayacağını ve Orta Doğu Teknik
Üniversitesi'ne gitmem gerektiğini
kendim ikna olduktan sonra ailemi ikna
edemedim Babam dedi ki Oğlum sen aptal
mısın diye başlayan cümle ile beni
tekrar oraya Çünkü bir gün hak
vermişlerdi geri dönme şansım vardı asla
dönmeyeceğimi söyledim ve o ki de
Hazırlık Okulu Bu arada babam bir trafik
kazası geçirdi o zaman da şöyle bir
muhabbet vardı arkadaşlar ceketimi
satarım çocuğum okutun ben 5 kardeşim
tek okuyan da benim öylece gets a tıkla
okumak o zamanlar çok da mümkün değildi
üniversite okumak ilkokulu-ortaokulu
okuyabilirsiniz
bu ve babamın kazası ile evde 9 10 ay
atmasından dolayı ben Orta Doğu Teknik
Üniversitesi'nde Mühendislik
fakültesinin hazırlık bölümünde
gerçekten fotokopi çektirecek para
bulamamıştım Tanrıya şükürler olsun ki
Keçiören'de yani Oturduğum yerden
Ankara'da ot diye kadar otobüsler vardı
ve biz alıp oraya götürüyordu bedavaya
akşam da getiriyordu yemekte Çok komik
bir rakamdı ben
bu aldığım devlet bursunu olduğu gibi
eve getiriyordum Arkadaşlar bu bir sene
hazırlıktan sonra hazırlığı da geçtikten
sonra
yatılı bir okulda okuma
zorunluluğum gelişti yani fotokopi
çekecek parası olmayan birinin ODTÜ'de
okuma şansı vardır ama ve ben daha biraz
da kolayı seçtim tekrar harp okulları
üniversite imkanı bir tercih sivil
olabileceğim için tek yer İTÜ Denizcilik
Fakültesi ki o zaman Deniz kuvvetlerine
bağlıydı Kaptan ve mühendis
yetiştiriyordu ve bir tercih o arkasında
Tıp Fakültesi GATA Arkasından da olur da
kazanamazsam diye tekel'in üstlenerek
bir Okulu Vardır her şeyini verdikleri
ve tütün eksperi yetiştiriyordu 3 tercih
yaparak sınava girdim birinci kazandım
okula girdim bu ve Evet her şeyimizi
verdiler bu devlete böyle büyük bir
borcum vardı bitir Ben bitirdikten sonra
da ikiye bağlandığı Bu okul Bu arada bu
borcu okula beş sene Sen yer direktörü
olarak ders vererek bu borcu bir kısmını
ödediğimi düşünüyorum arkadaşlar
E tabii babam yine çok kızdı bana otu
gibi bir okulu nasıl bırakırsın muhakkak
buraya devam etmelisin ben işte tarlamız
satarım kapağını satarım ve devam et
etmelisin diye
yine ben dinlemedim Babam yine oğlum
yine kaybedeceksin dedi Ben bu okula
yazıldım ve hayatımın en güzel en büyük
ve bana en uyan tercihini yaptığımı hala
inanıyor ve düşünür başka bir yerde
olsaydım hayat bana ne sunacaktır
bilmiyorum ama ben gene çalışkan biri
olacaktım bu çalışmadan olmayacağını
zekânın bir hikaye olduğunu Ben öğrendim
Arkadaşlar bunu çok erken öğrendim bunu
da hepiniz bilin bu Einstein zekâsına
sahip olabilirsiniz ama çalışmazsanız
hepiniz birer hiçsiniz arkadaşlar
Ya ben
abone ol
Sen bu okulu bitirdikten sonra her
şeyimizi karşıladığı için Devletleri ki
Hadi bakalım
bize hizmet edeceksin altı sene
bu ve İyi de maaş veriyor yine Fakat ben
çalışmaya başladıktan sonra fark ettim
ki
devlette çalışsanda çalışma sanda hiçbir
şey fark etme o zaman ki de ve deniz
nakliyatı sonradan kapandı Bu yüzden
arkadaşlar ve ben çok daha zor koşullar
ve aynı maaşları olmasına rağmen özel
firmaya geçtim ve çok ciddi bir de
tazminat ödedim yine Babam dedi ki bana
Oğlum
kaybediyorsun burada yata yata maaş
alacağım Hiç çalışmasam bile
geçirebileceğim bir iş var ne işin var
İngiliz Bayraklı gemide Panama Bayraklı
gemide diye ve ben uluslararası
gemilerde uluslararası personelle
çalışmaya başladı
ve dokuz senelik Denizcilik yaşamında
sınıf arkadaşlarımın ben en az iki sene
evvel kaptanlık yapmaya başladım Çünkü
çalışmak zorundaydım İzin kullanmadığım
için sınavlara girme periyotlarin daha
hızlı geldi ve girip yükselttim
gemilerde Kural şu önce üçüncü ya da
dördüncü Kaptan olabiliyorsunuz seyir
zabiti seyir subayı diyelim Sonra chief
officer 2. Kaptan oluyorsunuz sonra gemi
kaptanı Tabiri caizse su var ve eşim
dostum bana hala su var ve diye seslenin
ve Ben yabancı Bayraklı gemilerde en çok
ciddi maaşları alırken artık Deniz
tecrübemi yettiğini burada biraz daha
fazla kalırsam karaya asla
geçemeyeceğini fark etti hem denizde
hayal edin 12 bin dolar maaş alırken
karada bin dolar bir maaşta Çünkü yeni
başlıyorum o firmanın limanına Müdür
oldum Babam yine bana dedi ki oğlum yine
kaybetti
o Ve ben yine kazanmıştım Çünkü bir sene
sonra at maaşım 10 bin dolara çıkmıştı
altında arabam vardı lojmanın Vardı iyi
bir Tekirdağ gibi bir ilde 3'ün
protokollerde üçüncü dördüncü adam
olmuştu fakat battı Tekirdağ'da üçüncü
dördüncü adam olmak yerine İstanbul'da
beş zincir 500. 5000. adam olmayı tercih
ettim dedim ki Tamam bu bu da ya ilk
adımı attım karaya artık 2 3. adımlara
bakabilirim ve yine bu rahatlığı bırakıp
bir
şirketin gemisinde hem dış ticaret
müdürü hem de gemi müdürü olarak
başladım Babam yine dedi ki Oğlum
salakmısın aptal mısın diye başlayan bir
cümle ile baba dedim hayat uzun bir
maraton Ben burada bir stajyerim b bu
izlemeye devam et bundan öncekilerde
nasılki A2 yapmışsın A2 yapmışsın dedim
yine sana bunu dedirtecek dedim ve
Bu bir firma kurdum arkadaşlar küçük bir
firma önce bir sene profesyonel
yöneticilik unu Holding'de dış ticaret
Müdürlüğü bir gemileri vardı müdürlük
sonra gemilere hizmet veren bir firma
kurdu o firmada
tamir yapıyorduk bir sınıf arkadaşımla
ve denizcinin o kadar kötüye gitti ki
yani ben girdiğimde
dene olacağını bilmiyorum deneyimler
öyle bir şey ki Arkadaşlar şimdi mesela
denizciliğe ben yatırım yapılmaması
diyebilecek duruma geldim Beş sene önce
de bütün eşime dostuma neyiniz varsa
denize yatırım dedim yatıranlar büyük
paralar kazandılar yatırmayanlar da
kaybetmedi ver ama
kazanmamış oldular yani kardan
kaybettiler bu
Selam arkadaşlar
ve o bir sene boyunca de Belen'e de
böyle ne ayakta durmayı başardım
batmadık Ama çok zorluklar geçirdik
düşünün uzakyol Kaptan mısınız yani
uzakyol kaptanı demek geminin
Cumhurbaşkanı mısınız arkadaşlar Şöyle
ki
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'nde yalnızca
Cumhurbaşkanı bir de gemi kaptanı
kolluk kuvvetlerini Emir verme yetkisi
vardır gel diye Arkadaşlar bir
Cumhurbaşkanın da vardır Bu yetki bir de
gemi kaptanlarına her ne kadar bilmese
gemi kaptanları mı Şu anda o
evlendirme yetkileri haricinde böyle
güçlü etkileri de vardır Çünkü orası
dünyayı da gezen Türk toprağıdır
arkadaşlar
yok
buzunu Holding sonrası dış ticaret
firması Müdürlüğü sonrasında kendi ilk
firma mı kurduk bir sene
geliştirdik fakat
konjonktür Rusların dağılması bunun bir
fırsat olarak görün görmem Dolayısıyla
Ruslarla ortak bir gemi acentalığı
firması Kurdu Bu gemi acentalığı firması
Bu arada babam gene Aptal mısın oğlum
dedi arkadaşlar Ez yüzüm
herzamanki gibi
ben o
firmayı kurduğumda O işte kaptanlık
havasıyla gittiğinde kendi firmanda
hamallık bile yaptım arkadaşlar öyle
hayat çok kolay değil ya Sıradan bir
hayat Seçil orada işte en üstte oranın
en üstünde kalıp ya da hayır ben daha
yukarı çıkabilirim diye düşündüm
başardığımı en son Siz karar
vereceksiniz
o kızdan almayacağım bunu
ve bu Ruslarla kurduğum acentalık
firması Türkiye'nin en büyük bir
zamanlar en büyük olan Rus ortaklı
Transport for Denizcilik diye bir
firmanın hem hisseder oldum hem Genel
Müdür Yardımcısı oldum vb şans bu işte
Ruslar Türkiye'den çekilmeye karar
verdiler 99 yılında ve bu şirketi sen
alır mısın dediler ben alırım ama dedim
Siz çok küçüldü Bu firma para verirseniz
alırım dedim Bunun için Çünkü borçları
da var alacakları da var yağ alamazsam
diye bir de para aldım arkadaşlar uçtu
gitti alırken ve o şirket
en iyi Türk boğazlarında
3500 tane acenta vardır arkadaşlar
1500 acenta arasında mi yüzünü benim
teslim aldığımda yedi sene sonra
birinci olmuştu açıp bakabilirsiniz
Transport for Denizcilik diye 2010
yılında 2008'deki krizden sonra
denizcilik bir gemi sahibi olarak her
denizcinin hayalidir gemi sahibi olmak
bizim okul mezunu 2010 yılında artık bu
zamanın geldiğini ve
bu yirmi alınabileceğini o gün için kâr
etmiyor ama daha fazla düşebileceğini
nasıl ki Sayın ekonomi bakanımızın
nebati Bey dedi ya böyle dolar daha
düşemez en dipte en dipte diye gemilerde
endik değildi ben aldığımda fakat dolar
düşüyor Ben doğru demiştim gemiler bir
daha düşmedi arkadaşlar ve İyi de bir
gemiyle başladığımız periyoda
2022 yılında beşgeni bir ilaç firması 3
Otel
Bir de yeme acentası hala dururken devam
ediyoruz arkadaşlar buradan benim
hayatıma çocuklarıma da söylediğim şey
hep bu oldu sizin için doğruyu ben
bilemem Siz bilebilirsiniz ve sizin
vereceğiniz karara ben saygı duyacağım
babamın yaptığını yapmayacağım size
dedim oğlum benim yanımda çalışmayı
tercih ettik O kendisi firma kurup devam
etmeyi tercih etti onları da Özgür
bıraktım arkadaşlar
o Umarım bu konuşmalarımız dan bir
kelime aklınızda kalır bildiğiniz
doğrunun peşinden Sen ölümüne koşu
Bu bir inandığınız doğruların peşinden o
muhakkak yürü yürü kim sizi çekmeye
çalışırsa için elinizde ve o yolda
yürüyorsun Zafer sizin olacaktır
arkadaşlar